Film Courage: Passive versus active main character?
Paul Joseph Gulino, Associate Professor at
Chapman University Dodge College of Film and
Media Arts: Okay a passive person.
This is an opportunity situation because most
people assume and most movies are about somebody
who is active and they’ve got to do something.
But there are successful pictures where you
have someone who is not and how does that
work that’s what you look for everybody
says do this and this one doesn’t and it
still works, so why?
What did they do that compensated for it.
Because obviously if you have an active main
character it’s easy to watch.
You are going to see if they get what they
want or not and it’s all taken care of.
But what about that?
What you’ll see is there has to be conflict.
As long as there is conflict you will be okay
because the conflict will create the suspense
and the tension that evades us if you are
using dramatic tension as the main tool.
Not all movies do.
There will be ensemble pieces that will be
following a bunch of different stories and
different characters and the unifying element
is the milieu like DINER.
It’s about a diner, it’s what happens
in a diner.
And as long as it’s understood by the audience
that that is what they are watching it’s
a signal about what it’s about.
In fact that movie is a 1982 picture.
I believe the opening title is The Week Before
Christmas 1959 (something like that).
Maybe 1958?
It’s about cults or something.
But it gives you a sense right away from the
opening that it’s going to take place in
about a week.
It actually starts Christmas Eve and it actually
takes place in a week.
So that frames it and then you have an ensemble
and there are competitive conflicts with those
but the overall conflict doesn’t utilize
dramatic conflict as bait so it doesn’t
have that.
You have first acts involving different characters
and different subplots and a subplot has its
own act structure (generally).
There are a couple that kind of dangle off
and disappear (the main ones do).
But if we go back to the most common form
which is a character with an objective and
there is obstacles an active one helps.
There was a famous editor I was told about
and I don’t know who it was but that the
secret to the craft is that all scenes are
either chases or escapes.
People are either trying to get something
or trying to avoid something.
And a passive character is just somebody who
is trying to avoid something and the key is
to build a circumstance where that is hard.
Like LARS AND THE REAL GIRL, we talked about
that.
This is a movie where we have a passive main
character where all he wants to do is…it’s
an escape story because the whole town has
united to not let him do what he wants to
do by very indirect means playing along.
But you can see the tension is there and surrounds
the question is he ever going to get better?
So that would be the passive main character.
Or I like [ONE FLEW OVER THE] CUCKOO’S NEST.
What does this guy want to do, he wants to
avoid doing any work.
He wants to play cards!
He doesn’t have any agenda beyond that.
But the way the story is constructed it’s
the worst possible situation for his unique
characteristics which is that he is a noble
person and he wants to help people and this
world crushes him.
So that’s something you can look for.
Film Courage: THE GRADUATE…sorry.
Paul: THE GRADUATE, he doesn’t have to pursue
her but I do have an analysis in the book.
He doesn’t have to pursue her, she is in
his lap.
There is nothing there.
But what keeps us suspended there is that
it’s not an escape movie, it’s dramatic
irony.
You look at the middle part of that movie
example where the second act is actually not
that long, it’s about equal in size with
the first and third act.
The second act is really about whether he
will get caught and you have comic irony played
with (and sometimes dramatic irony) where
the mother inquires “Where do you go every
night?”
He cuts himself while shaving.
You can see he is not comfortable answering
“Oh I just drive.”
Or in the hotel where everybody recognizes
him and he is with the girl and Catherine
Ross the actress at the hotel where he’s
been having his liaisons and everybody knows
him and he’s trying to conceal from her
what was happening.
SUNSET BOULEVARD is a movie about this guy
who is trying to hustle this older woman (he’s
a writer) and after a certain point, really
from the middle of the movie on, he’s really
passive.
He’s kind of avoiding the world.
But it’s an escape in that way, he’s trying
to stay away from everything and the world
intrudes.
But largely that one is sustain by a little
bit of tension about somebody trying to not
let him escape and a voiceover narration which
keeps us…it is a form of telegraphing “This
is about to happen.”
Or little did I know this would happen so
that we are anticipating.
So the answer to the question can you have
a passive main character look for where the
conflicts are.
If the character is passive and never wants
to do anything, can you put them in a situation
that challenges that and makes them fight?